this morning Venezuela is deporting an
American journalist who says he was
detained for more than two hours at the
presidential palace Jorge Ramos was
interviewing President Nicolas Maduro at
the time violent and deadly protests
continue in Venezuela over u.s. bank two
opposition leader Juan Guido's
challenged to medoras power and while
mejor cos is in cucuta Colombia near the
border waves of protesters faced off
again with pro Maduro forces Monday we
were going to stand up for Venezuela
even if they don't want to support us
this young man told us we will find a
way in a sign of the fracturing regime
our cameras captured a Venezuelan
military officer fleeing to Colombia to
escape the growing crisis in a new
interview president Nicolas Maduro
blamed the United States for quote
trying to fabricate a crisis to justify
political escalation and bring a war to
South America Univision journalist Jorge
Ramos says he confronted Maduro about
that and showed the president this video
of young Venezuelan citizens eating food
out of a garbage truck he says he and
his crew were abruptly detained in a
darkroom for two hours told us that they
didn't authorize the interview and they
confiscated all our cameras for cameras
the incident happened just hours after
vice president Mike Pence met with
opposition leader Juan Diego across the
border in Bogota Colombia announcing new
sanctions against minutos government if
the tragic events of this past weekend
have only steeled the resolve of the
United States of America to stand with
you meanwhile those along the border
remain fearful Ramona Kara Scott lives
in Colombia
she says she ran for cover choking
during those deadly clashes as for tear
gas canisters landed in her home and
bullets flew overhead are you concerned
about what's gonna happen next episode
this is just starting in your view yes
more than 50 countries have now
recognized Juan Y dough as Venezuela's
inner impress
but despite some defections Maduro still
appears to have strong support within
the military signaling this could become
a prolonged conflict for CBS this
morning I'm Manuel Bojorquez in cucuta
Colombia